there are very good reasons for C
occupying a special place in the
firmament of languages although I think
one thing to say at the outset is really
it finds its maximum power its maximum
resin or even existing at all if you
think of it as being the classical
system implementation language again for
younger viewers it's going to be hard to
understand and comprehend this but if
you go back to the early mainframe era
you're getting really really powerful
computers well both those days standards
coming along in from the early 60s
onwards they were so expensive they had
to be time shared between lots of users
and that in turn means you've got to
have system software the can multitask
between different people different
people's programs loaded into the
machine at the same time all being timed
sliced with a little bit of time but at
the same time increasingly computer
systems had to evolve into not just
being able to print out your output in
your answers but the stories in the
follow they had to run file systems and
by the early 1970s you are in this
incredible situation that one of the
biggest challenges in programming a
real-time challenge where you had to
keep people happy was nothing more or
less than the operating system in your
computer one of the hardest challenges
going and yeah the wisdom was you will
only ever be able to do this in
assembler some of the low-level tricks
you need to do in operating systems you
know the real man attitude real men use
assembler and I think a lot of people
said no there's some truth in that but
on the other hand just a little bit of
higher-level operations if only it could
be done without slowing the language
down too much
would help us stay sane I think a lot of
people gradually were if you like
embellishing assemblers to become macro
assemblers to try and give the kind of
higher-level approach to things that you
got in high level languages but on the
other side the opposing arbors always
saying I love a language they're so
inefficient you need assembler for
everything ideally Moore's Law paid to
that you know yes we can afford to use
high-level languages for a lot more
things in the early seventies then there
were a lot of experiments in trying to
usually to adapt existing languages for
system implementation use and
particularly ones that have started to
building some low-level operations for
bit twiddling it was getting important
where to dig down to the byte level and
get out characters looming up just on
the horizon shock horror as if 16 bits
wasn't a toy computer eight bits coming
so you needed a language to evolve that
could cope with different width of
objects of course as it becomes you go
through a sort of like a minimum in the
curve you know we have to chop things
down in size because otherwise we can't
make it at a price that people will buy
but then as Hardware becomes cheaper
generally you then turn the corner and
you could see it even in in deck and
there pdp-11 minicomputers soon enough
they come along with a 32-bit computer
which they can afford to make at long
last and of course that was the era when
discrete transistors and components on
printed circuit board gave way to chip
technology so you have like LSI Elevens
it's large-scale integration it's not
separate components anymore
and graduated curve turns the other way
how did this change in architecture
feedback into the language choices then
well I think that it's two things first
of all can you get a system implement
in language that helps you do low-level
things at a higher level and I still
think that probably probably could say
the most successful of all time and on
that front was say it's not really one
to others or things like bliss there
were things like even Algol 68 and other
high level languages BCPL were tried out
but C had the great advantage that you
could see how you might port it ah yeah
Dennis can all that they're doing out in
the pdp-11 they'll be doing it on the
facts but up come the sons all of a
sudden the son servers hey can we pull
UNIX to this with reporting units got to
get the C compiler working can you get
the C compiler working yeah yes of
course you can and it really stood the
test of time I mean when you look now in
the GCC compiler at the architectures
that are supported it just writes its
own brochure saying just look at this we
can cope with anything however the other
side of that was that the then the
differentiation to if you like
higher-level languages even imperative
ones just became more marked and I think
it was very interesting that I think it
was in the mid to late 80s James Gosling
of Sun effectives hey it's people who
run programmers and see how many
mistakes they make when they're using
pointers and as far as I recall it one
of the design requirements of Java was
we're gonna ban pointers that use a
level when we start looking at why
programs go wrong it's people who've
made mistakes with pointers so therefore
we're gonna ban them and actually not
against that if you really don't need to
do low-level manipulations of pointers
then let the language do it for you
or if it's like C++ where you could do
them and you say I don't want to do all
my clever stuff under the hood I'm not
writing an operating system yeah get
hold of a library full of functions and
trust them because they'll have been
tested
they'll be efficient and all this kind
of thing so yes
things like function
languages which of course always used to
still do get flack for being so slow
they became more and more possible to do
they I suppose ratified said they got
less and less inefficient you know but
no it was a liberation to have that much
compute power around that you didn't
have to think too much I'm glad that
many sensible souls on the comment
streams of recent videos have said this
it's no good getting theological about
you're not a real program if you don't
program in sales anything silly like
that you've got to have an attitude of
horses for courses the right programming
language for the right task if you're
yelling out to use Python use Python if
he's yelling out to use all because I've
been known to do yeah I tried out as you
know my my read and mother messages from
Mars I got it hacked it together in all
well why not you can always take the
view that if it's not any efficient
enough we can drive down to a lower
level more efficient language but the
ability to try things out without them
taking hours and hours because really
fast hardware is probably about the
biggest liberation I can think of in
terms of my professional career as a
computer scientist you know I'm not a
program I mean one day it might make a
video my bad exploration of basic in my
youth but as a non programmer I suppose
I come at this and think well why can't
there be one thing that fits all and my
kind of taking kind of examples from
other parts of life presumably certain
things are good for certain things let
us say I think that's right I think that
you see it in all sorts of other realms
in life is that you know the true
professional tool for doing something it
was probably very different from a user
level to you know I mean if you go to a
hardware store and buy yourself a drill
with a hammer action you know that's a
very different object from what they
would use industrially to hack into
buildings it's in principle the same but
the whole spec and construction of it is
is very different and that's what we
that's what we now have the ability to
do is to fit the language to the task of
course it still leaves a big problem
that lots and lots of software ideally
should have been rewritten years ago
because the moment you get something
that's good for its time and works the
temptation is just to leave it in place
because it works and we don't change you
got so many things are dependent on this
so this is why there are still 8-bit zhe
programs doing heaven knows what in the
Armed Forces
there are probably still companies out
there in the wild still using COBOL and
mainframes you know cost of a mainframe
simulation these days peanuts that
program cost us a fortune to rewrite it
and is bound to go wrong and it's known
and reliable so that thing about having
legacy software and hardware and it's so
difficult to trust to replace again it's
still is going to be a problem eternal
you know I think that well there is a
well-known phrase if it ain't broken
don't fix it what helps the ain't broken
bit you see that's the thing is that if
there's something rather exotic on the
hardware front from the 1960s you no
longer have to literally build one of
those you can simulate its action so as
long as you put a lot of effort into
getting a good simulator going then you
can carry on with the code you've had
for 30-40 years in some cases
so sometimes he floppies word dies he
often would make backup copies let's try
this one sounds more hopeful and so
there was this game called
Lander which became the full games arch
and when this game was released it was
sort of full 3d graphics